foreign
let's go to Ava in Richmond Virginia
what's up Ava Hi how are you I am most
excellent how are you
yeah so you're not good it's okay to say
it what's up
um so my question is
um as you know the holidays you're
dealing with families
in-laws and um
we had a trip with my in-laws and um
and I've been with my uh
husband for uh we're gonna be 18 years
in Feb No 19 years in February
congratulations together forever thank
you thank you and he's my
we have two kids
and I mean we've been through
so much together and um you're about to
say he's your what
he's my high school sweetheart
um
I'm sorry but it's it is what it is cool
that's love I love it I love it I love
it and
um so
I
fell in love with him and all this stuff
because he's he's a really good I think
he's a good person but um you know
throughout our relationship we've sort
of had issues with my mother-in-law's
not really nice woman
um and I was really I'm I was when I
first started I was saying a very nice I
uh in my culture you know and I think in
a lot of cultures but
um
they're very big on respecting Elders
like it's a very
like it's it's very like it's very big
what's your culture
I'm Ethiopian okay
um and so it's very big in in that in
that aspect and so when I met his mom
she would just be the meanest evilest
person in the world and you know I come
give me an example
an example is um
I came home and I was living with her
um
I came home from finding out that um I'm
adopted by the way so having a family is
very big for me and my um I came home
that I found out that I was um I was
already four months pregnant I knew that
I was happy but I was having issues and
I came home and I lived with her and she
stood there and she speaks a different
language from me but um
she stood there in front of my husband
and said you know you killed the baby
right and I could understand at that
time because I've been with him about
two years so I could understand Spanish
um so I'm so sorry
I mean
they said
things but um
times where
I was fluctuating with my weight and
depression and you know
um
of uh and and all these things and so
um she would just say like oh you're too
fat for my son or she would say like
um just a lot of mean things just
and my husband saw it like he where is
he in all this
he just didn't say anything he said
that's just my mom and she'll stop she
said hey but dude he needs to step up
man oh so he's definitely you know he's
um a coward yeah yeah yeah so no dude
he's
a coward he's the first boy he's the
first boy she's um Hey listen I couldn't
care less I'm the first boy in my house
yeah well his father is not in his life
so I feel like listen if my mom said
that to my to my wife
I mean that wasn't his wife at that time
you were about to be the mom of his baby
yeah but he allowed it and he's
continued to allow it
and he's continued to allow it oh yeah
but you know over time I sort of what he
wanted is for me to stand up to her and
so that was a little bit oh that's his
job it's his mom
I know so that was a little bit
um that was the most difficult because
in my culture you're not even supposed
to like
come to an like someone that's older
than you in that aspect and so I
continued to sort of in my head there's
a cultural aspect 100 you you honor you
honor
um
Elders to the end of time you go down to
the bottom of the ocean on that ship I
get that
yeah there's also something you're not
admitting to yourself and that is your
husband is leaving you out to dry
oh yeah I would I would tell him that if
he was on the phone I wish he was on the
phone because I don't like talking about
people
but he's another room I can get him for
you he has got to
say Mom we are not coming to your house
anymore
because of how you talk to my wife the
mother of my children
period conversation ends
I wish that is that because
um it just kept rolling and more things
happen and then we'd get over it I
wouldn't talk to her and I would stand
up for myself and he's like good job
you're standing up for yourself and and
you know me like I said I'm a doctor I I
was in so many years of my life where I
was not protected by anyone and I didn't
need anyone to protect me but I felt
sort of yes you did we all do we all do
I do I do we all do we all do
no we do
I still do but um okay so what happened
do you have a big blow up did you go to
war
so my mother-in-law we wanted her to be
with us because me and my husband we
when we traveled we're like hey we have
an extra room you can stay in that room
you have your own bed your kitchen
everything awesome and she was fine and
then like when her other kids start
coming
she sort of like tends to take things
out on me because I'm easy to take out
on you know I'm not related to her so
it's easy to be mean to me and so she
would just say certain things like oh
you know like I love to cook I love to
like I just you know I wanna I'm very
um
I think one of the things my husband
maybe doesn't like about me is that I'm
very
I think about others a little too much
and maybe I don't think about myself
um but I I was like you know that's
probably because he loves you and cares
about you and watches you
you know drive yourself into the ground
trying to be a peacekeeper right
all right go to it go to it we're
getting up against the clock go to it no
okay so what happened is um we had a big
blow up
our I said something and I um I
disrespected my husband in front of her
what'd you say um and then I said
I said it's really bad I said
I Am The Unlucky dumbass being with you
and uh that sounds like Kelly says that
to me all the time well his mother said
something in regards of
I didn't want to curse but um I already
did but she sort of said
um you know you're she said I don't want
this
b-i-t-c-h to talk about my son or treat
my son like this now mind you I
I take I think me personally out of
anyone that they know they know my
husband their their brother their son is
treated better than their own house they
know that like I I believe everyone in
the family knows he is taking care of
this is somebody who is yes was what you
said mean yes fine
that's somebody who is looking for any
tiny tiny little crack yes yes to just
blow right through it to knock the whole
building down
yes so she so so the whole thing is that
like I would say this if my wife said
that about me in front of my my dad my
mom they would laugh and they would say
yep nah okay I just want I want to give
you some other context my parents are
great people my parents love me dearly
but they also trust my wife implicitly
yeah like a daughter not like some weird
like tumor that's been added on to our
family
okay so that's how she treats me how can
I how can I help
so my thing is the whole blow up
happened it got physical because she
pushed me Oh I pushed her back I am Gina
yeah okay
we were it was I've never touched like
it was really bad anyways my issue is
throughout the trip my husband and me
discussed it and I said hey you have to
protect me you have to put a pause on
your mom even the sisters were telling
him like be careful with my like
everybody knew and so my question is how
do I I told them from now on I don't
want his mom in my life that's just it I
don't want her in my life I just don't
think I know how to respond when someone
attacks let me say that let me say it
let me say it this way for you
yes your your mother-in-law has opted
out of your life
because you owe Ava safety
and you owe Ava peace
and you owe Ava dignity and respect
and this person I don't care if she is a
stranger somebody at the bus stop or
your mother-in-law
has chosen
to physically assault you to disrespect
you to take your dignity away from you
to make you feel less than on a regular
basis to prop herself up in her place in
her firstborn son's life
and so you're not kicking her out of
nothing
yeah she has chosen to not be a part of
your life because she doesn't treat you
like a human being
full stop
so I don't want you walking around with
the burden of guilt
and don't let your husband put that on
well we can't go because you won't be
around mama no
your mom has what do I do then like for
my son and my daughter like the great
Jay-Z says you brush your shoulders off
and go on to the next
but she's like what did I do if it's
family events
sweet if she chooses to if the rest of
the family chooses to have her there
then they are choosing to not have you
there and that's fine
don't go if she goes there don't go
there why would you go there I don't
know to experience violence to
experience disrespect and listen you're
teaching your kids
yeah that's the sad part your husband is
teaching your kids hey when somebody
attacks your mother or my wife we just
keep going back for more we just keep
going back for more I don't say nothing
that's her problem
so I should just like for the relation
how do I stay out of the relationship
between because I've never been I've
always said hey Juan you know um sorry
hey Don can you please contact your mom
can you please um
how she's doing nope
he is if he chooses to have a
relationship with her great that's
wonderful
um
unless it's not right I mean if he
forgets her birthday that's a choice
he's made
you're not his mommy
yeah so stop stop pushing that that's
how yeah I mean here ultimately it's a
it's a non-confrontational I'm not
fighting anybody
okay I'm gonna tell my husband I'm gonna
tell my wife
hey I just want I'm I'm drawing
boundaries you've told me that this is
my fight for my whole life you've never
stepped up to help me out so I've I'm
choosing how I'm ending this fight
I will not go to events if if with with
your mother there
she's she is chosen to
um
not be around me and so she's not going
to be around my kids
I can't tell you what to do you're a
grown man if you want to go to family
get-togethers and whatever you're
welcome to do that my kids
um I don't feel safe with them there
no I can say
I don't want to hurt anyone I just this
is a little girl who's still wondering
why her mom and dad
Center away
yeah
yeah Ava you were loved
so it's okay then to say to and it's not
mean if I tell my husband hey you know I
you can go but my kids are gonna I don't
feel safe with my kids being with her
absolutely even if my kids want to go
your job my kids want to eat donuts 24 7
365. my job as a parent is that's not
safe right it's not good their insides
will melt it's like it's it's it's it's
that's my job as a parent
my son wants to go ride four-wheelers
he's not gonna do that he's you know
what I mean like it's not safe and so
it's my job and so yes
there is a hundred a hundred percent
every reason to believe
that the animosity and hatred that that
woman has displayed to
the wife of her son
uh-huh will be transferred to your kids
absolutely yes
no question about it I also think it's
very very fair
and it might not be the season but it is
very fair
okay to tell your husband
that you're heartbroken that he never
stood up for you
heartbroken
she's not talking to him either because
she's because she's a child she said
she's a child
she is a spoiled brat child
period yeah she's not talking to him
because uh she said he didn't even stand
up for me he said to her you're making
my life difficult and she said oh my God
he told her that and when he told her
that she got so upset and said how can
you go against me
you know I am your mother how can you go
against me and he told her I'm not going
against you the kids told me you put
your hands on my wife and then and then
also hurt the little there was a little
girl involved that she hurt and so I was
defending and so even to yesterday I
asked I said are you upset at me you
know because we're having huge issues
now and he's like no I'm not I'm not
upset at you because you defended
yourself from my mother I knew my mother
was going to do that to you I I knew
when I walked away knowing that
and to me I guess with that that breaks
my heart that breaks my heart for Him
man
yeah I wish he just sort of I wish you
could just
to me like
long like all I want from my husband is
just to say I have not defended you all
this time and protected you as what it
should have been my duty I said hey have
you said that to him because it's in
there now you've not said that out loud
before have you
times
he left you he's left you to defend
yourself great I'm not going anymore and
I want you to
um
this is gonna be something that you
practice but I want you to
say that with peace in your heart
I want you to say that with joy and
optimism me and the kids we're going to
a water park
we're going to stay in a hotel and we're
going to have pizza and movies and just
be ridiculous for 48 hours that's what
we're gonna do you're I would love love
for you to join us
but if you want to go there that's great
okay it's disgusting and disrespectful
for a in-law to put themself between
their child and their child's spouse
it's the it's one of the lowest forms of
immaturity because that should be a
relationship that parents should be
championing and cheering for and lifting
up
so glad that you of all people picked my
son and I wouldn't have picked you for
him I think you're weird I think you're
not the right culture I think you're not
the right whatever religion but my son
picked you and I raised a good guy I
trust him
and so he picked you
we pick you we're all in
that's how that should be and it should
be every single thing I can do to lift
you guys up
yeah not everything I can do to get
between you two I need to remember I'm
the mom here no dude no it's wrong it's
wrong it's wrong Ava and you're not the
crazy one for two decades you have not
been the crazy one
okay is it is it um
bad
or is it wrong
that I throughout this whole time you
know I I thought about her like I
actually thought about like how is she
doing
the hotel like listen listen listen for
her stop thinking that your feelings are
bad or wrong
they just are yeah
yeah okay what you what you choose to
meditate on
yeah if you go down a roll like a rabbit
hole like I just want the worst for her
I would say that's no that's not right
you know what I mean or if you opposite
I know I know I'm just saying more for
her or if you choose to start sending
her emails from a secret account just to
harass her that's your actions aren't
right okay your thoughts and actions you
can judge those your feelings they just
come man they come
and you have never had permission to
feel
yeah and so yeah dude you if you if
that's the kind of person you are oh
gosh I wish we had more Hearts like
yours did somebody hurt you and on their
way out you wonder hope they're okay
oh there hope they're okay
that's that's pouring heaping holes on
the head of your enemy man like because
you you literally hope no it's not bad
it's not good it's probably not wise to
then call and reach out and try to
repair that relationship as though you
did something wrong because you didn't
yeah you popped off about off about her
son who cares it's not worth physical
violence it's not worth hurting a little
kid
you're good
you're good and maybe for the first time
this is a season how about this I want
you to get a journal I want you to start
writing able letters
about how you feel what you're worth
what you wish had happened and more
importantly what you need going forward
and these can be some awkward hard
conversation with your husband but
foreign
not to leave you out on an island
emotionally or physically
y'all are in this thing together
thanks for trusting us thanks for giving
me your call